dans les yvelines le mouvement
génération est en territoire connu mais
loin d'être conquis ancienne terre
d'élection de benoît hamon le mouvement
cherche à s'implanter et pour y parvenir
il faut d'abord séduire des électeurs de
gauche
encore sonnés après la suite des
défaites électorales
quel regard vous portez justement sur ce
mouvement naissant mais je ne connais
pas trop alors justement j'ai peut-être
d'en savoir plus ce soir je militerai
pour rassemblement des gauches en fait
la pta course est très dispersé si je
peux vrai dans ce domaine c'est ce c'est
mon voeu marqueur emblématique pour la
gauche le mouvement génération avait
choisi d'évoquer ce soir là la
thématique migratoire un sujet où les
différences avec le gouvernement sont
nombreuses et faciles à trouver une des
vocations du mouvement générations c'est
d'apporter un regard différent sur la
manière dont on doit être bienveillant
auprès d'eux
concitoyens qu'ils soient micron a par
ailleurs invité de cette réunion
publique le maire de grande synthe dans
le nord est venu témoigner de son
expérience pense qu'il faut rétablir des
chiffres il faut rétablir des réalités
est ce que j'ai vécu c'est un gars sympa
en accueillant 2500 exilé sur le
territoire de la ville en ouvrant un
camp pour 1300 d'entre eux montrent que
c'est possible de le faire et donc on
dédramatise ont fait tomber tous les
fantasmes qu'il ya autour de cet accueil
des réfugiés
le projet de loi s'il et immigration
sera débattu en avril à l'assemblée
nationale c'est alors la france
insoumise qui devrait porter la voix de
l'opposition dans l'hémicycle